[Music]
asus rog phone to the phone with every
speck maxed out the absolute dream phone
on paper so the question is how well do
specks on paper translate to real-world
use in a phone and is pretty much the
perfect phone to find that out this is
one of those phones that people sent me
a whole lot to check out because well I
made that dream phone video a little
while back where I had all these crazy
specs that I wanted to see in a phone
and then Asus announced this and the
spec sheet people said Oh mark is it
looks like they made basically your
dream phone so I picked it up and I've
been using it I brought it to the Apple
event that I've been using this phone
for more than a week now and I can tell
you exactly what I think but this is the
spec sheet I just I just want to put
this in one place for all of you who
will appreciate this just listen to this
world-class spec sheet snapdragon 855 +
12 gigs of ram one terabyte of ufs 3.0
storage a six point six inch 120 hertz
OLED display a 6,000 milliamp hour
battery and 48 megapixel dual cameras on
paper this is the best phone you can buy
in almost every metric best chip most
Ram biggest storage fastest display
biggest battery straight across the
board and with room still for a
headphone jet so how does absolutely
dominating a spec sheet actually
translate to real world use spoiler
pretty good so first of all the design
the package that you stuff all the specs
into it's pretty similar to the first
ROG phone they've toned it down a little
bit you know there's a little less
copper a little less thin action but
it's still unmistakeably a gaming phone
of course the aesthetic isn't subtle and
the design is a bit more subjective it's
not really on the spec sheet this is
just what it looks like if you're cool
carrying around a phone that looks like
this or not and there's a certain type
of person that will be I'll say the
number one thing you'll notice more than
the glowing logo more than the vent
cutout for cooling more than the circuit
lines and the design that reflect a
rainbow or a glow colors is that it's
just absolutely huge like there are
small phones and there are big phones
this is a huge phone
you need a big footprint to fit all
these specs and then since it's made
mostly of metal which is dense and with
that battery this is a really heavy
phone about 240 grams to be exact and
you really feel that weight in your
pocket and holding this thing I'm cool
with it I like big phones but you might
have to see it or hold it in person to
really like actually feel how big it is
that's what she said and then from there
a lot of the design choices are made
specifically with the gamer in mind but
a lot of them just end up being nice for
people who just like media in general so
things like the USB type-c port is down
on the side here so you can still charge
it while holding the phone sideways and
it doesn't get in the way there are also
dual front-facing stereo speakers and
they are incredible speakers you know in
a world where headphone jacks are slowly
dying off but being replaced by a
wireless audio the dual stereo
front-facing speakers set is also an
endangered species and I'd like to bring
awareness to that and there really isn't
much of a great replacement they're just
worse speakers now but yeah these are
really good crisp loud and clear so
overall the design of course isn't for
everyone in fact I prefer something a
little cleaner a little bit more
understated but there is a lot of good
choices here so I can respect that so
okay then the specs first main specs are
Snapdragon a 55 plus and 12 gigs of DDR
4 Ram so of course it's gonna be
extremely fast launching apps and then
keeping a lot of them in memory and
flipping through them yeah having the
highest end available specs here does
great but then there actually are some
other things that make it feel even
faster number one is the ufs 3.0 storage
it's really fast storage that's helped
phones like the oneplus 7 pro and the
galaxy fold feel much faster including
installing apps really quickly and
launching apps really quickly and then
number two is this display it's a six
point six inch 120 Hertz AMOLED 1080p
panel and so saying that out loud is
that's a pretty unique spec sheet that's
a great number but you got actually look
at it it is a very fast display actually
the fastest mobile display that I've
ever seen you can turn it down to the
normal 60 Hertz if you want you can bump
it up to 90 Hertz or just keep it at 120
all the time like I did and it also has
a 240 Hertz touch response refresh so
it's super quick and responsive to your
touch scrolling for example is super
smooth you of course can't really fully
appreciate it through this video which
is only 30 FPS but I guess take my word
for it it's really snappy I think is the
keyword very smooth and snappy so
scrolling the UI and any app of course
that supports the higher framerate look
awesome there's a whole list of games
that support it but I've said it once
and I'll say it again high refresh rate
all the things please but it's not the
best looking OLED in the world it's
1080p for one which on a 6.6 inch screen
is not a huge deal but it's worth noting
like it's not a low resolution it's
still almost 400 PPI but versus a 1440p
display you can't tell the difference
and then colors and contrast just felt a
little strange to me at times it has
adjustable color profiles but I never
quite felt happy with the color
calibration it gets up to 600 nits which
is decently bright but it doesn't get
very dim at night which I actually found
much more annoying when it's dark and I
wish my phone wasn't so freakin bright
it also has a fingerprint reader
underneath the display glass and it's
nowhere near the best ones I've used
it's not always glitchy but it is
glitchy more often than any other ones
I've used it is definitely optical as
you can see you know with the light
shining on my fingerprint as it tries to
read it and it also has this weird
artifact that's kind of hard to capture
but at lower brightness when you go to
unlock with your fingerprint the whole
display sort of bumps up in brightness a
little bit and gets really grainy and
weird looking as it reads then just goes
back to normal when it's done it's not
actually a problem or anything but it's
just a fascinatingly weird thing to see
happen so specs it's got those for sure
but like always you have to look a
little bit past the numbers to find and
see interesting things like that but
then speaking of numbers here are some
other numbers to think about up to a
terabyte of built-in storage so that's
that's pretty great there is no
expandable storage but let's be real you
probably don't need more than a terabyte
so that number translates pretty well
and then 6000 this is a six thousand
milliamp hour battery and that as you
can imagine also translates through
well that is the biggest battery I've
ever used in any smartphone even at a
hundred and twenty Hertz all the time
I've never gotten close to killing this
phone in a day on a super heavy day with
me where I had a lot of unplugged
navigation and music streaming and I
just intentionally never plugged in
during the day I ended the day after
10:00 p.m.
with about five hours of screen on time
and half battery left Wow
just I don't know it's my dream
smartphone battery literally never ever
worrying about if I'm gonna have to
charge during the day and then just plug
it in every night you could probably go
on a weekend road trip and not bring
your charger and come back two days
later with like 30% battery for real and
if you're ever worried for some reason
you're gonna have to go like four
straight days without charging like this
is the dream scenario for a battery in a
smart phone you could just turn it down
to 90 Hertz or turn it down to 60 Hertz
and you're good for a while so yeah this
is a that number 6000 translates very
well then here's another number 48 it's
a 48 megapixel primary camera on the
back at F 1.79
this turns out is one of those specs
where you can just kind of ignore the
number you might be tempted to believe
48 megapixels automatically means it's
good but this you know it's a decent
camera I'd give it a B b-minus for
quality maybe with great software tuning
or G cam it could get up to a B+ but
it's not blowing anyone's minds here
images can look pretty good when you
give them a lot of light of course and
it does have great HDR but sharpness and
color I've noticed and white balance are
more inconsistent they can hit or miss
and there's actually a bit of noticeable
shutter lag which I thought was strange
for a phone that's otherwise so
incredibly fast but it also has a 13
megapixel ultra wide at 125 degree field
of view and similar to some other phones
I'm glad it has one but the
inconsistency between the two cameras
especially as far as color and sharpness
and detail is major so you know it's an
extra fun camera to have but clearly not
as high quality this has kind of been
one of the themes I've noticed about
gaming phones though is that people who
use these don't really take a ton of
photos or care as much about the
critical quality of photos on videos so
the cameras are just good enough matter
of fact for reference
a reviewers guide for the phone just to
go over all the features and things I
should check out it's 41 pages long and
the camera stuff is not talked about at
all until page 36 so you know I do
actually want to give a sous major props
or something though so if you remember
the first asus rog phone that software
was a little bit over the top the the
themes and the icons very gamer ii and
the mechanical sounds and it was a bit
much so i did criticize it a bit in that
first video well an ROG phone - when you
first set it up you get the option to
choose between that very heavy ROG UI or
this sort of near stock clean Zen UI and
that is what I like to see I am now
happy with the software experience on
the ROG phone - I of course chose the
new Zen UI and so there's no Goudy icons
or robot sound effects or anything crazy
like that it's something closer to maybe
like an oxygen OS or any other light
skin on Android not sure about the
upgrade schedule still Android 10 is
starting to roll out and it's just kind
of a pixel thing for right now but I'm
impressed with what we have here so far
there are still plenty of gaming
features of course though it wouldn't be
a republic of gamers phone without that
there's still the armory create and game
modes Game Genie X mode the system
lighting control it's all still here
don't worry there's even improved air
triggers on each side of the phone for
gaming and landscape but if I'm being
perfectly real I don't play a whole ton
of like really intense games on my phone
I don't play fortnight on my phone so
like I guess it says something that even
a phone that's not targeted directly to
me has still been so enjoyable to use
this is a really great phone now is
probably still gonna go a bit under the
radar just because it's not gonna be in
carrier stores and it's a gamer phone by
a smaller company so it feels much more
niche but if you get excited about this
type of thing or if you're a gamer on
your phone or if you just saw the spec
sheet and went that looks sick then you
are squarely in the target demographic
of people who will really enjoy using us
it's not perfect you know there are
small trade-offs the cameras aren't
world-class the all metal body is solid
of course and it's going to be heavy
but also means no wireless charging and
there's also no official water
resistance or IP rating and the phones
Achilles heel really is just the size of
the damn thing
so here we are at the end of the review
if you're finding yourself sitting there
thinking wow I really want to know if I
can tell the difference between that 120
Hertz and 90 Hertz versus 60 with my eye
and I can't wait to play these games at
high frame rates yeah you'll love this
phone you know so turns out the spec
King on paper does deliver in real life
and it also turns out design is very
important but let me know what you think
do just the specs make it the dream
phone or would you buy this phone just
for the specs over something a little
more tame I'm curious what you think let
me know either way thank you for
watching catch you guys in the next one
peace